>> Tucker: FOR YEARS NOW
GOOGLE HAS BEEN
PHOTOGRAPHING AND BUYING
PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE EARTH'S
SERVICE FROM SPACE AND
UPLOADING THEM ONLINE GOOGLE
EARTH PROGRAM.
PHOTOS OF THE UNITED STATES
ARE UPDATED FREQUENTLY WITH
ONE MAJOR EXCEPTION.
FOR AT LEAST 8 YEARS
IMPANELINGS OF THE TEST
RANGE IN NEVADA HAVE GONE
WITHOUT AN UPDATE.
IT'S ALMOST AS IF GOOGLE IS
HELPING THE GOVERNMENT HIDE
SOMETHING.
IF THEY WERE HIDING
SOMETHING, WHAT MIGHT IT BE?
NIC POPE IS A JOURNALIST
SPENT MANY YEARS
INVESTIGATING UFO SIGHTINGS
FOR THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT.
NIC, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
DID I STATE THOSE FACTS
CORRECTLY THERE IS OUT OF
THE ENTIRE CONTINENTAL
UNITED STATES ONE AREA THAT
IS NOT UPDATED REGULARLY ON
GOOGLE EARTH AND THIS TEST
FACILITY MAINTAINED BY THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT.
IS THAT CORRECT?
>> THAT IS CORRECT, YES.
IT IS VERY CLOSE TO THE
INFAMOUS AREA 51, WHICH IS,
OF COURSE, WHERE UFO ENTHUSE
ENTHUSIASTS SAY WHATEVER IT
WAS THAT CRASHED AS ROSWELL
IN 1947 WAS TAKEN.
THE TEST RANGE IS ABOUT
70 MILES AWAY FROM AREA 51.
AND, AGAIN, IT IS ONE OF THE
MOST SECRET PLACES ON THE
FACE OF THE PLANET.
UFO ENTHUSIASTS AND THE
CONSPIRACY COMMUNITY SAY
THAT'S WHERE THE ALIENS ARE
AND U.
IF OS WE ARE TRYING TO
DEVELOP TEST FLOWN.
AVIATION ENTHUSIASTS SAY
IT'S THE NEXT SITE OF
GENERATION OF PROTOTYPE
AIRCRAFT, DRONES AND PERHAPS
HYPERSONIC WEAPONS ARE
TESTED.
THERE WAS A BLIND SPOT FOR
YEARS.
>> Tucker: IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THE FIRST CAMP
IS RIGHT OR ON TO SOMETHING?
IS THERE ANY EVIDENCE THAT
THE U.S. GOVERNMENT DOES
HAVE KNOWLEDGE OF UFOS THAT
HASN'T BEEN SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC?
>> WELL, THIS ALL TIES BACK
TO THESE RECENT REVELATIONS
ABOUT THE PENTAGON'S UFO
PROGRAM.
AND THIS WHOLE -- THE RUMORS
ABOUT AREA 451 AND CRASHED
UFOS AND TRYING TO PUT SOME
OF THIS TOGETHER AND FLY IT
OURSELVES, THOSE RUMORS HAD
GONE AWAY BUT THEN WE HAD
THE STORY ABOUT THE
PENTAGON'S PROGRAM.
WE SAW, OF COURSE, THOSE
VIDEOS OF THE NAVY JETS
CHASING THE UFOS, AND WE NOW
HAVE SOME OF THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THAT PROGRAM
SPEAKING OUT AND SAYING,
YES, THERE WERE THESE
UNKNOWNS IN OUR AIRSPACE.
IT'S NOT JUST AIRCRAFT
LIGHTS AND WEATHER BALLOONS.
>> Tucker: INTERESTING.
IS THERE ANY INDICATION OF
WHAT IT IS THEN IF IT'S NOT
JUST AIRCRAFT'S AND WEATHER
BALLOONS.
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
THE WHOLE TROUBLE WITH THIS
AND THIS REALLY LINKS THESE
TWO STORIES OF THE TEST
RANGE AND THE PENTAGON
PROGRAM.
THERE HAVE BEEN THIS
BLURRING OF THE LINES, EVEN
THE PHRASEOLOGY, THE
PENTAGON'S PROJECT WAS
CALLED ADVANCED AEROSPACE
THREAT IDENTIFICATION
PROGRAM.
SO AS I SAY HAVE YOU GOT
THIS BLURRING OF THE LINES
BETWEEN WHAT IS JUST OUR
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY AND
WHAT REALLY MIGHT BE, IF
SOME OF THESE RUMORS ARE
TRUE, FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S SO
CONFUSING AND, OF COURSE, I
THINK THAT DOD, PENTAGON HAS
EVERY RIGHT AND, IN FACT, AN
OBLIGATION TO KEEP PROJECTS
ITS WORKING ON SECRET.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY SO MUCH
MATERIAL, SO MANY DOCUMENTS
FROM 50 YEARS AGO, 40 YEARS
AGO, 20 YEARS AGO WOULD
REMAIN CLASSIFIED TO THIS
DAY.
WHAT COULD BE THE
EXPLANATION FOR THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU ON
SECRECY.
I MEAN, I'M NOT CALLING FOR
THIS TO BE OPENED UP, EVEN
THOUGH A COUPLE OF MORE
RECENT PHOTOS HAVE NOW BEEN
PUT ON GOOGLE EARTH.
BUT, EVERYTHING YOU PUT OUT
THERE, OF COURSE, THE
RUSSIANS CAN SEE IT, THE
CHINESE CAN SEE IT.
EVERYONE CAN SEE IT WE NEED
TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IS OUT
THERE.
AND I THINK THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT FINALLY WE ARE GETTING
SOME U.S. CONGRESS INTEREST
IN THIS.
THE SENATE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE ARE NOW LOOKING
INTO THOSE NAVY VIDEOS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN AND DISCUSSED
AND THE HOUSE SERVICES
COMMITTEE ARE LOOKING AT THE
PENTAGON'S PROGRAM TO SAY
WHAT DID WE GET FOR OUR
TAXPAYERS' DOLLARS HERE?
>> Tucker: LAST QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT
AND MAYBE SOME COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN WOULD HAVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THIS?
THEY HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW.
DO YOU KNOW DO YOU THINK
THEY DO KNOW THE ANSWERS?
AGAIN RUMORS ARE THIS IS
WHAT THE SPACE FORCE IS ALL,
ABOUT I'M NOT SO SURE ABOUT
ALL OF THAT I THINK THE
PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE IT KNOW
IN HIS CAPACITY, OF COURSE,
AS COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
SO I HOPE THAT THERE ARE
SOME INTERESTING SECRETS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COME OUT
O'ER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS IF
WE GET FORMAL CONGRESSIONAL
HEARINGS ON THIS AS OPPOSED
TO JUST CONGRESSIONAL
INTEREST, WE WILL WAIT AND
SEE.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE
DEFINITELY OUT THERE.
THE QUESTION IS WILL WE FIND